Silas Robertson better known as uncle sy
has been entertaining people with his
quirks and hygiene since 2012 when he
was first featured on A&E stag dynasty
reality series how was the player before
they invented the game jack along with
his ever-present iced tea glasses he
shot to household recognition and went
on to become the most popular person on
the show uncle syan is catchy sayings
decorate many a piece of duck dynasty
merchandise and he's even received the
coveted chia pet treatment however duck
dynasty ended in April of 2017 and
Robertson retired from working at duck
commander the duck call manufacturing
business featured on the show hey so
where is sy Robertson today and what
keeps him entertained ever since he left
the immediate national spotlight as it
turns out uncle sy is a
jack-of-all-trades when it comes to
hobbies he's tried his hand at writing
music making and of course a viral video
analysis which he conducted alongside
his nephew Willie Robertson and his
short-lived spinoff series going Cyril
that rapped surely before duck dynasty
dead virtually the moment the show ended
Robertson released a book in May 2017
entitled serenity how I stay calm and
keep the faith the book is something of
a behind-the-scenes slash memoir that
looks back at his entire life including
his time spent on the A&E reality show
but this was actually Robertson's fourth
published book it came after psychology
1 tales and wisdom from duck dynasty's
favorite uncle and two children's books
uncle syan the Christmas elf and
everything's better with a beard which
features the entire Robertson clan
since then uncle SI's decided to lean
full tilt into a music career by
founding his own country music group
uncle syan psychotics the band consists
of Robertson his daughter-in-law Marcia
Robertson and celebrated
singer-songwriter Bridget Tatum
they recorded a single chord as seen on
TV in 2017 and subsequently released a
self-titled EP
before the end of duck dynasty under
what was arguably the apex of his
mainstream fame Robertson expanded his
reach on the small screen by appearing
on the television series Last Man
Standing
playing a character called uncle ray
opposite Tim Allen in the 2013 episode
back-to-school he also dabbled in
feature films landing a small part in
the 2015 Christian religion film faith
of our fathers Hey
so good you'll punch your mama he also
lent his voice to narrate VeggieTales
Mary Larry and the true light of
Christmas however the bite of the acting
bug didn't have long lasting effects
robertson hasn't stepped in front of the
camera since duck dynasty ended in 2017
and it seems that won't change anytime
soon as his focus is on uncle syan the
psychotics Robertson explained in a May
2018 interview with pop culture and he
had grown accustomed to a certain way of
life during the heyday of duck dynasty
but he isn't about to let a lack of
riches keep him from a career in music
something he had previously attempted in
2014 with the release of his EP me and
my smoking hot honey he explained I got
to start making me some money somewhere
but I chose the wrong industry to really
make a lot of money I think there's a
lot of girls that we want to meet as a
band I would love to see that we finish
this record out because I would love to
see what we could write beyond what
we've got I think everybody believes it
to be just this funny thing and there's
a lot of that on there but there's also
some moments that happen on there that
are really important and I would just
love to be able to have the opportunity
that we can all write together some more
and see how deep we can go finishing a
full-length album is the band's current
priority as uncle syan the psychotics
are no longer actively touring the
country if you want to keep tabs on them
they regularly post videos on their
Facebook page even though duck dynasty
is over sy Robertson's life clearly
hasn't stopped for a second when I say
that you know what Hyrum
hey that's Picasso will mean that it'll
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos buy
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]